[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en
bourgogne et en franche comté en direct
pour ce grand débat du premier tour des
élections législatives
un débat que vous pouvez suivre aussi
sur facebook où vous pouvez vous
exprimer
les lignes politiques ont-elles bougé
depuis la présidentielle les premières
mesures envisagées réforme du code du
travail moralisation de la vie publique
vont elles peser le contexte
international aura-t-il aussi une
importance et au final qui aura la
majorité 18 juin toutes ces questions
nous allons les poser à nos invités
bourguignon et franc-comtois bonjour
catherine bonjour lilian alors je
commence cette représentation par hélène
pélissard c'est la première
vice-présidente au conseil départemental
du jura où elle s'occupe des affaires
sociales elle représente ici les
républiques à face à elle se trouve
françois patriat
il représente la république en marche
ancien ministre ancien président de la
région bourgogne il est actuellement
sénateur de côte-d'or et c'est l'un des
premiers parlementaires socialistes à
avoir rejoint emmanuel macron les liant
noirot est élu conseiller municipal à
montceau-les-mines également au conseil
régional de bourgogne franche comté
il représente ici le front national il
est d'ailleurs secrétaire départementale
de ce parti pour la saône-et-loire et
puis nicolas baudens est élue socialiste
à besançon et à la communauté
d'agglomération
il est premier secrétaire fédéral du ps
pour le département du doubs
c'est à dire que c'est lui le patron des
socialistes pour le doubs
et puis je termine par alexandre emorine
il représente la france a soumises et le
coordinateur de la campagne du parti de
jean luc mélenchon pour la côte d'or
nous sommes un mois jour pour jour après
le deuxième tour de la présidentielle
est-ce qu'on en est au même point
regarder ce sondage ipsos steria pour
france télé publié hier avec une
projection en sièges qui donnerait une
majorité de 385 à 415 siège pour
emmanuel macron hélène pélissard quand
vous voyez sondages surtout le camembert
le camembert bleus qui est pas bien gros
vous vous dites que c'est déjà perdu etc
la droite dans la foulée de la
présidentielle ne l'emportera pas
au plus haut les sondages se sont
souvent trompés donc je ne suis pas
persuadé en même temps est ce qu'on fait
à peu près la même chose pour cette
espèce
écoutez on a on a vécu une sorte de
tsunami
l'élection d'un président de la
république qui n'était pas connu trois
ans auparavant un qui nous dit qu'il est
ni de droite ni de gauche qui à 39 ans
une fois qu'ils étaient lus il choisit
un prêt d'un premier ministre de droite
des ministres à droite et à gauche et il
souhaite gouverner le pays moi quand je
regarde le programme d' emmanuel macron
il ya un certain nombre de mesures qui
sont tout à fait compatibles avec le
progrès ça veut dire comme le disait
tout à l'heure l'ayant que les lignes
bougent bien sûr les lignes bougent
il y à des mesures qui sont compatibles
avec le programme des républicains par
exemple la modernisation économique du
pays elle est nécessaire il faut faire
bouger notre pays et nous en sommes tout
à fait conscients là où nous ne sommes
pas du tout d'accord mais où nous disons
aux électeurs attention ne respect
attend sur ce cas lambert n'est pas une
bonne chose pour notre pour notre pays
c'est que le financement de la du
programme d' emmanuel macron n'est pas
possible on ne peut pas faire peser
encore 20 milliards d'euros
c'est ce qu'on a eu une heure entre nous
nicolas baudens donc pour le parti
socialiste sur le camembert
donc il ya peu de sondage oui et ce
sondage il y a peu de bleu il ya encore
moins de rose est ce que le parti
socialiste est mort non le parti chez
lice n'est pas mort tout simplement
parce que pour l'instant ce sont des
sauvages nous faut imaginer quand même
que les gens doivent encore aller aller
voter par contre c'est inquiétant parce
que j'ai l'impression que sur un parti
en marche qui va globalement de alain
madelin à robert hue si la seule
alternative c'est mélenchon et c'est le
pen ça pose un vrai problème
démocratique
donc je pense qu'effectivement le mac on
risque d'avoir une majorité
brossard est c'est un risque parce que
je quand on voit ces chiffres là je
pense que les chiffres sont beaucoup
trop importants et je pense que ça lui
posera un problème si effectivement il a
tous les pouvoirs
on parlera tout à l'heure de valider des
ordonnances il va se retrouver qu'une
majorité qui risque d'être introuvable
et il est ingérable tout simplement
parce qu il y aussi beaucoup
voulzy lui qui vont arriver on va parler
plein renouvellement je disais en
ouverture est ce que les lignes bougent
parti socialiste avec une présidentielle
compliqué je pense qu'on dira pas le
contraire est ce que dans ces dernières
semaines à dire vous avez le sentiment
que voilà que c'est vous êtes sur la
même tendance et que c'est vraiment un
mauvais moment et que le l'unité du
parti se dégrade aussi en ce moment
l'unité extrêmement compliqué et nous ce
qu'on attend c'est effectivement la fin
de cette période électorale qui était
très très compliqué avec un mauvais
score aux présidentielles un score
plutôt délicat pour les législatives
et nous c'est dès le lendemain du second
tour des législatives en fait la
refondation du parti socialiste et de la
gauche effectivement là dehors on est
obligé de 7 lié à ce style
alors puisqu'on parle de refondation du
parti de la gauche je viendrai fait
alexandre emorine il y aura une
refondation après on a aussi le
sentiment quand je parlais des lignes
qui bougeait qu'après un avant premier
tour de présidentielle assez euphoriques
dans votre camp les choses se passent
pas exactement de la même manière qu'à
une forme de retour sur terre alors on
le voit dans les sondages on le voit
aussi peut-être dans l'attitude de jean
luc mélenchon vous le sentez ça aussi
sur le terrain non justement sur le
terrain en voile inverse on évoque la
dynamique il continué
alors c'est peut-être un peu moins
médiatisé parce que c'est vrai qu'on n'a
pas jean-luc mélenchon par seconde alors
écoutez moi que nous quand on veut en
tout cas dit fais des tracts rencontrer
des gens quand on organise des réunions
publiques en tout cas on peut vous dire
que les gens sont de plus en plus
nombreux aussi à venir à nos réunions et
pourrait vous cacher sont même plus
nombreux qu'avant la présidentielle
parce qu'on a je pense les normands de
gens qui sont rendu compte qu'on n'est
pas passé loin
on est passé à 600 mille voix près on va
pas refaire le match mais en gros en
gros on est bon on n'est pas passé loin
par contre ce que je voudrais dire par
rapport au sondage du kof camembert mais
qu'un sondage on est d'accord qu'il ya
une autre
c'était un point de départ parce que
c'est le dernier qui a été fait pour
france télé de sortie mais qui est
surtout une intention de vote au premier
tour je ne captais deux tours une
élection législative donc quoi qu'il
arrive ça ça n'aura pas lieu et en même
temps ça montre bien si cette version
n'a pas montré d'intentions de vote
qu'on a montré les projections en sièges
ce qui n'a pas vraiment on va dire d'une
certaine réalité c'est sûr par contre ça
montre bien si ça devait avoir en tout
cas ces proportions mais je n'y crois
pas que la vème république ne représente
plus du tout la réalité politique et
sociale du pays et donc ça montre bien
qu'on a raison de proposer une sixième
pascal or là ce serait ce serait
terrible sur sur l'ensemble du
territoire
donc on a l'impression que la france est
soumise à bien du mal de gérer ses 7
millions de voix à la présidentielle
et on va voir au législatif savané voilà
c'est un ressenti pour le front national
on peut dire qu'il y à a après débat du
second tour avec marine le pen qui
reconnaît elle même qu'elle a été
mauvaise vous non plus sur le terrain ça
se passe pas forcément très très bien
écouter sur le terrain nous on a on a un
très bon ressenti je me permettrait déjà
de rebondir sur un sur sept sur cette
projection
cette projection des mondes parfaitement
le fait que les lignes ont bougé d'un
côté on a deux blocs un les patriotes
que représente le front national que
représente également debout la france et
de l'autre côté les mondialistes entre
le parti socialiste qu'il en reste en
marche et les républicains d'ailleurs
madame pays sart a parfaitement à
démontrer cette coalition qui était qui
était celle qui était celle d'arles vous
pouvez trouver qu'on vous prend beaucoup
en début d'émission mais il ya aussi un
autre sondage qui a été fait qu'on
aurait pu vous montrer qu'ils montrent
que dans l'esprit des français les deux
seuls partis qui sont des forces
d'opposition
c'est certes vous mais aussi la france a
soumises donc dans les lignes qui bouge
on peut peut-être voir les choses d'une
autre manière en effet mais bon le voilà
donc les 11 millions d'électeurs
patriotes du deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle ont démontré d'ailleurs
sur le terrain on a toujours ce ressenti
le gouvernement d' emmanuel macron
bassesse un condensé rare de
personnalités qui sont les unes autant
que les autres aussi opportuniste
qu'inquiétante
on a d'un côté un bruno le maire ou
encore un gérald darmanin qui évoquait
le poison macron et un bruno le maire
qui durant la primaire de la droite et
du centre
j'ai tout vous n'arrivez pas quand même
à mobiliser à rassembler vos troupes et
un sondage vous allez dire que les
journalistes aiment beaucoup trop les
sondages qui dit que 42% des électeurs
de marine le pen ne se déplaceront pas
dimanche 1 la tendance en effet pour les
élections législatives
on est d'accord vous perdez beau pour
voir les antilles les électeurs de tous
les partis politiques confondues se
mobilisent - et donc c'est pour ça que
j'en profite ce soir autour de autour de
cette table d'inviter tous les électeurs
patriotes à se mobiliser davantage cette
élection législative c'est le troisième
tour de l'élection présidentielle
françois patriat quand vous voyez ça
vous vous dites il ya une courbe
ascendante qui passait pas le premier
tour au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle et qui continue à monter
ou ça vous semble beaucoup trop gros
pour être vrai à les oublions camembert
bilan mairie avançons à pas comptés pour
faire un mauvais jeu de mots sur le
fromage de notre territoire ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est pas dans ce
sondage là que je le vois c'est dans
d'autres études d'opinion d'abord les
français majoritairement approuve la
formation du gouvernement
majoritairement
à plus de 50 % et en second lieu j'ai vu
une étude d'opinion aujourd'hui qui dit
que 63% des français souhaitent donner
une majorité au président parce qu'ils
se disent quoi ce président alors on va
oublier tous les clichés de madelin
terrade et bertin pour des patriotes ont
pas oublié tout ça et puis on va aller
voir la réalité parce que ça c'est de la
caricature et du schéma d'élections qui
n'a pas profité
non pas du tout les corps au
gouvernement de mélange man-made n'y a
pas ça c'est clair donc pas oublier va
oublier mobile eden tchicaya les dans
cette campagne qu'est ce qui a changé
parce que c'est le chef de l'état
lui-même qui aujourd'hui conduit et mène
la campagne
defacto dans l'esprit des français les
français savent pas quand il n'est pas
sur les plans de la campage aider mais
malgré tout c'est pas seulement les
images qui donnent ces les gestes qu'ils
impriment qui le font depuis que avant
on avait beaucoup de doutes cd il avait
pas de partie on ne connaissait pas il
serait jamais candidat c'était le faux
nez de hollande il avait pas de
programme qui serait pas candidat il
serait pas élu qui a pris leur a pas de
majorité
et voilà petit à petit tous les doutes
se lève la stupéfaction des gens très
disputée les factions de venise
il faut lui donner sa chance n'ont pas
choisi comme je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est ce que j'ai entendu monsieur
descendu 3 récession comme en sachant
pas sa chance il le dit c'est parce
qu'ils disent exactement ils disent
aujourd'hui nous avons un chef de l'état
qui imprime fortement à la fois sur le
plan national et international qui d'un
seul coup sûr le plan régalien où tout
le monde doutait de lui s'impose aussi
bien pour la sécurité d'un seul coup les
français disent eh bien ce président
doit réussir donnant nuit les moyens de
réussir et sortons des petits schémas
clanique des partis anciens qui n'ont
pas voulu vu le monde s'écroulait autour
d'eux alors le mondial alice et cetera
les schémas classiques
j'entends bien mais c'est en regardant
le monde tel qu'il est que nous
reprendrons chemin faisant les deux
réponses allen faillissent à rixensart
d'abord monsieur monsieur patriat
moi je suis je suis assez d'accord avec
vous pour dire que les débuts de
monsieur mac ronde emmanuel macron sur
la scène internationale ont été dépôt
des bus mais pour que ça se transforme
en réussite il faut que le pays france
se redresse et pour que le pays france
se redresse
il faut que nous ayons des comptes qui
s'améliore moi je vivais encore hier le
président le hier encore le président de
la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale disait le
programme de macron ses 60 millions 61
milliards mais pardon soixante milliards
d'économie sur sur cinq ans 50 milliards
d'investissements sur 5 ans donc il ne
reste plus que 10 avec ces 10 milliards
là d'économies sur cinq ans on inverse
pas la coudre on ne tombe pas à 3% de
déficit et on ne rentrent pas dans les
critères de maastricht et la france ne
sera pas écouté mais elle sera raillé le
nom parce que nous allons donner des
leçons à des gens sans être capable de
mettre de l'ordre dans notre pays que
j'aime pas interrompre
mais je vais vous répondre vous n'êtes
pas allé au bout de la logique le
programme c'était qu'il ment 60
milliards 50 milliards mais les 60
milliards dont vous parlez après c'est
tous les ans les économies c'est tous
les ans après ce qui permettra de
diminuer le déficit de la france ce qui
permettra d'investir
après quand on europe tu les soixante
mineurs qui sont répétitifs tous les ans
tous les ans tous les ans plus de cinq
ans alexandrine sur les économies vous
aviez c'était aussi par rapport à leur
disais tout à l'heure où j'étais assez
d'accord avec vous sur l'aspect nouveau
monde politique on est rentré dans un
temps dans un 21e siècle politique on
voit que les partis traditionnels que ce
soit le parti socialiste où les
républicains le disent très bien ils
sont totalement macron compatibles le
parti socialiste dit même jean
christophe cambadélis qui veut aider le
président bon bah écoutez on voit
qu'aujourd'hui les seules forces qui
restent qui reste en place la seule
force en tout cas crédible face à
emmanuel macron qui soit aussi humaniste
et républicaine c'est la france a
soumises et moi je tiens à dire aussi
une chose c'est que emmanuel macron n'a
pas une majorité d'adhésion sur son
projet il faut pas oublier qu'il a été
élu à 65 % au 2e tour lui en france
c'est le deuxième président et vous
doutez mieux élu face au front national
les gens n'ont pas voté pour emmanuel
macron de voter 2 contre marine
c'est en ça que marine le pen est la
meilleure alliée au final emmanuel
macron puisqu'elle permet à tous les
labels 25% au premier tour et la même
chose pour face à une candidate
d'extrême droite tout comme jacques
chirac
en revanche quand on regarde son action
au niveau national depuis le début du
mandat
pour l'instant c'est en résumé ce
silence radio dire autant acquis au
niveau international les poignées de
mike trump poutine etc
c'était largement relié au niveau
national il ya la loi de moore
réalisation sur laquelle jouent
globalement je pense la majorité le
parti on est d'accord sur la
modification du code du travail via les
ordonnances on avait prévu par les
ajustements
c'est l'étape suivant effectivement
c'est sorti hier à la sortie c'est chaud
voilà rappel des faits hier donc un
projet a été présenté par le premier
ministre et par sa ministre du travail
muriel pénicaud il a surtout fixer une
méthode et un calendrier alors voici les
principaux points qui devront être
examinés notamment avec les syndicats
c'est le plafonnement des indemnités
prud'homale la fusion des instances
représentatives c'est-à-dire fusion des
délégués du personnel des comités
d'établissement et des chsct ou encore
l'articulation de entre entreprises et
branches
concernant le code du travail à la tête
de chacune des entreprises alors
françois patriat
pourquoi maintenant pourquoi ce code du
travail maintenant
alors est ce que c'est pour simplement
montrer une volonté de réforme en
profondeur donnée à un signal de ce côté
là mais ce que ce n'est pas aussi dans
le même temps risqué parce que vous
allez certainement j'allais dire
ressusciter la gauche face à ce projet
alors d'abord je voudrais vous rappeler
ce qu'a dit le chef de l'état lorsqu'il
est allé voir madame merkel il le dit
voilà l'europe que nous allons refonder
et ça c'est la première fois que le chef
de l'état depuis 20 ans dit cela autour
d'eux autour des travailleurs détachés
autour autour d'un certain nombre de
mesures d'antidumping la fiscalité la
sécurité et en même temps c'est là que
julien grissault normale dans des seaux
en même temps il a dit nous allons faire
des nous allons faire des efforts et
c'est en cela qu emmanuel macron écrite
parce qu'il va proposer des efforts
autour d'un diptyque est très facile
protéger libéré en même temps la france
la france n'attend pas les chômeurs
n'attendent pas les entreprises
n'attendent pas si on repart dans un
débat style loi elle comrie qui va durer
six mois qui sera votée dans neuf mois
qui sera appliquée dans un an et demi
l'économie n'attendra pas le dit maryse
est de défendre les ordonnances et bien
entendu les ordonnances le coeur d'abord
s'il vous plaît est ce que il faut
réformer aujourd'hui le marché du
travail pour créer de l'emploi s'était
exhibé la loi elle que rien ne montre
qu'il faut aller général de gaulle
mitterrand on va en parler d'eux
ordonnance mais d'abord le coeur quand
même de la loi travail et collabos oui
monsieur france comité ont effectivement
l'isr de danse c'est la retraite à 60
ans et si la cinquième semaine de congés
payés en 80 alors effectivement la prof
de danse effectivement il ya préférons à
la rigueur ne m'attendais là on avait un
sondage de l'eure qui ont montré qu'ils
venaient ma compo à majorité de 400
députés à l'assemblée nationale et on
est obligé de gagner trois ou quatre
mois en évitant un débat au parlement à
nommer naira débattant il y aura et loi
d'habilitation les lois de rap efficace
et riche sur le front et le parlement et
le sait et le sénat l'assurance et je ne
connais pas sûr qu'en flexibiliser le
droit du travail
on va en résumé faire diminuer le nombre
de chômeurs 2 1 millions ou 2 millions
de chômeurs car quand vous regardez en
allemagne au dernier jour de la clavette
action entre les autres chômage et ou en
allemagne mais d'autres images et ou en
angleterre aujourd'hui ils en sont à
cinq ans nous on est à 10 en allemagne
un niveau de protection analogue à celui
de la france mme à l'heure actuelle à
tout chômage très faible et en même
temps on se rend compte de la banque il
ya énormément de travailleurs pauvres en
allemagne sinon il ya aussi un truc de
société qu'est ce que nous voulons pour
préférer des chemins
sinon les riomois non mais on aurait pu
le garder
de quelques mois voilà les lyonnais waro
donc pour le front national par rapport
à ce code du travail la réforme qui a
été présentée hier quelle est votre
position
alors nous nous sommes fermement opposés
1,7 à cette réforme là le projet d'
emmanuel macron c'est un projet de casse
sociale
c'est un projet qui suit la ligne dictée
par l'union européenne c'est une loi
elle comme riz puissances disent qu'ils
vont encore piétiné le débat
démocratique
vous défendez la la le fait de légiférer
par ordonnance mais c'est c'est
proprement scandaleux à 7 cette réforme
également du marché du marché du travail
elle va accroître davantage la
précarisation des salariés et en
particulier des femmes parce que ce sont
les grandes oubliées toutes vos
politiques convient également de le
rappeler l'entreprise
non je ne savais pas que je suis c'est
là où je suis je suis salarié je gagne 2
smic donc je connais les difficultés des
salariés sont pas triés
donc monsieur patriat ne s'est pas coupé
donc cette cette réforme là elle va
fragiliser donc d'autant plus les
salariés mais également elle va donner
davantage de moyens au grand patronat
parce que ce ne seront pas les chefs de
tpe de pme qui vont sortir des grands
vainqueurs de cette réforme et en est
loin mais l'a par exemple sur les
indemnités de prudhomat je me permets de
vous vous coupez sur le plafonnement
n'était prud'homale c'est une demande de
chefs d'entreprises de ppe par exemple
et pme vous disiez celle des grands
gagnants vont être les patrons des
grandes entreprises mais il ya des
demandes de chefs d'entreprises sur le
marché du travail aussi des pme par
exemple mais j'étais en débat avec la
capeb de saône et loire 1 cette semaine
et je peux vous dire que le ressenti sur
le terrain est bien différent que les
ressentis parisien donc pour en revenir
quand même à 7 à cette réforme là ça va
être le chaos social le cdi va être mis
en danger le droit du travail qui
protège les salariés va être mis en
cause
les salaires vont être effondré et puis
les chômeurs aussi vous être contraints
d'accepter n'importe quel travail qui ne
fera référence à aucun domaine de
compétences qui leur sont propres à ce
que monsieur patriat j'ai une question
pour vous dans ce dans ce projet de
réforme du travail
j'ai pu lire
que monsieur macron visait à suspendre
le versement des indemnités chômage à
partir de deux refus d'offre raisonnable
d'emploi en période de chômage de masse
où les français peinent à trouver un
emploi pérenne qu'est ce que vous
entendez véritablement par offres
raisonnables d'emploi alors c'est pas un
peu pro des propos généraliste et
simpliste quand même bien répondre mais
moi je suis heureux de voir que le front
national et plus a été plus à gauche que
la france assouplisse que vous découvrez
que vous devrez la pauvreté que vous
découvrez la misère sociale que vous en
vivez ce fait bien longtemps que
l'éléphant dans le but illicite et aux
carreaux mais ne s'est pas interrompue
donc moi je pense aussi à ces tout six
chefs d'entreprise qui ont quoi
aujourd'hui qui veulent créer de
l'emploi qui attendent quoi des carnets
de commandes qui attendent du travail et
qui veulent pas embaucher des gens et
qu'ils n'ont pas envie
manifestement de licencier des gens il
préfère la garder et pour ce faire et
leur faute de choses il leur faut de la
visibilité des marchés et de la sécurité
etc en leur apportant la sécurité parce
que demain mois 2 2 caps et les
prud'hommes de masse est quelque chose
qui me choque par là parce que le
harcèlement sexuel n'est pas concernée
par ces choses là et c'est qu'il faudra
mais c'est par par ailleurs par ailleurs
le fait de n'avoir aucune visibilité moi
j'ai dirigé une association qui parce
qu'elle a perdu cinq cent mille euros au
trou aux prud'hommes fans de trois
salariés à déposer le bilan a mis 22
personnes au chômage et a laissé 150
jeunes sur le carreau
mais je peux très parfois là où il faut
nous espérons qu'ils feront face à
murray a permis donc après sur les
offres elle nous permet d'écouter la
portant en contrepartie vous avez oublié
de dire qu'en contrepartie des deux
offres pour doper proposé il ya le
chômage pour tout le monde
le chômage pour les artisans le chômage
pour les agriculteurs le chômage pour
les indépendants des tridents shima
shima les indépendants ils auront droit
au chômage
ce sera dans les mesures qui seront
prises très prochainement et dans les
lois de finances
allez on va passer au progrès parti sur
la question notamment sur la question
des prud'hommes
vous êtes au courant quand même que les
prud'hommes c'est en cas de licenciement
abusif vous avez peut-être vu verser
avec votre association des sommes aux
prud'hommes
c'est probablement parce qu'il ya un
licenciement abusif et on sent que ça
permet des chiffres est opposé à choisel
permettent de chiffrer et s'opposer dans
les comportements délictueux à distance
soit y avoir je ne mens pas seulement
les hommes de votre année pour la
rentrée parce qu'il va y avoir quand
même par des normes et des rendez-vous
par définition des nationales qui parle
de précarisation des salariés et qui dit
que c'est une loi pour le grand patronat
et qui ont donc il est accusé à gauche
que vous ferez rien fait que marine le
pen dit elle même qu'elle ne veut pas
augmenter les salaires alors moi je suis
très content voir monsieur patriat dire
que les entreprises ont besoin d'un
carnet de commencer le constat qu'on
dresse depuis des années sauf que pour
qui un carnet de commandes il faut que
les gens puissent consommer il faut donc
qu'ils aient les moyens de consommer et
donc augmenter les salaires marine le
pen disait elle-même qu'augmenter le
smic c'est une mesure bolchévique je
crois enfin bref et l'emploi y est dévié
et ancien un petit peu de l'extrême
droite ensuite sur la forme aussi sur
sur les ordonnances parce que venons
aussi source sûre cette forme là les
députés en marche montre bien qu'ils
vont être totalement inutile à
l'assemblée puisque leur premier vote ce
sera de dire aujourd'hui on ne vote plus
ou à la rigueur on dira oui ou non
moi j'suis désolé j'attends d'un député
autre chose que dire oui ou non
j'attends un débat éclairé qui
permettent ensuite de prendre une
position qui soit tranchée pour la
nation et enfin sur les je prendrai
aussi sur la question de l'indemnité
chômage indemnités chômage aussi qui
sera concerné par cette par cette
réforme
en gros vous voulez changer totalement
le mode assurantielle aujourd'hui du
chômage l'assurance chômage
en faisant peser pas sur la csg donc sur
une assise beaucoup plus large donc sur
les retraités
un retraité 2002 il ya eu 1200 euros de
retraite il perdra 300 euros par an et
gagnera à 800 euros de taxe d'habitation
donc ils organisent facile apparemment
bien que 80 mer sont détenues ce d'edf
il ya des mesures de droite qu'ils
doivent ou mère quand même ou non mais
moi que
on libère le droit du travail et qu'on
rendre la france plus compétitive
ça me paraît non seulement nécessaire
mais absolument indispensable donc c'est
pour vos électeurs qui ont fait ça
maintenant emmanuel macron 1 3 jours
emmanuel macron investi dans son
programme depuis le début ça fait partie
et je les dis des réformes que nous
pourrons voter bien évidemment voilà
vous savez la france aujourd'hui un pib
manufacturier de 8%
c'est à dire que 8% de la valeur que
l'on fabrique en france c'est nos
entreprises de ce sont les entreprises
de fabrication ses 22 % en allemagne on
peut pas continuer comme ça il faut bien
libérer le travail
il faut donner aux entreprises la
possibilité d'embauché de prendre des
marchés donc il est indispensable
d'aller là dessus bien qui a fait faire
le travail aujourd'hui enfin moi j'ai
vraiment une question on parlait
toujours de les libérer le travail qu
est-ce qui l'enferment essai qui avait
fait un code du travail vous savez
pourquoi il est aussi épais on part
toujours de l'épaisseur du code du
travail c'est parce que le le medef
notamment y met des exceptions le code
du travail il est très simple la durée
du temps de travail le salaire la
protection la santé points le res et les
exceptions bien faire de cette famille
là il faut supprimer un certain nombre
d'exceptions et c'est ce qui va se
passer
apprendre à travailler uni qui sont
visées d'accord voilà donc c'est le
genre de réformes sur lequel on peut
suivre effectivement il peut y avoir des
majorités de sur certains projets en
revanche et vous avez dit vous même ces
4 milliards 800 millions par an que de
donner l'assurance chômage aux
indépendants et aux indépendants et aux
agriculteurs un c 4 milliard huit cent
mille ça nous on voudrait savoir comment
vous le financer je vous dis la france
ne peut pas continuer d'aller dans le
mur alors vers on va peut-être faire moi
je voudrais entendre nicolas baudin à
propos des ordonnances
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que les
ordonnances jeu choquer mais les
ordonnances sur la loi travail vont
permettre de gagner du temps quand même
vous pensez pas que c'est une bonne
chose mais gagner du temps peut imaginer
que le débat parlementaire veut se
résumer à la semaine du 24 au 28 juillet
avec une adoption définitive de six
ordonnances à la fin du mois de
septembre
vous vous imaginez avec une grande
assemblée où emmanuel macron seraient
potentiellement grandement majoritaire
un débat avec du nouveau député sur une
semaine sur un sujet aussi important que
cela on aurait pu faire deux mois de
débats je pense que la france aussi
recenserait remise mais pas conduire est
un nom dans le quinquennat précédent et
ça est fait quand même beaucoup reproché
les français avaient l'impression qu'en
fait rien ne se passait rien avancer
mais les livres en 2010 les français ont
des pistes il a loué le connerie mais je
pense qu'ils vont vraiment haïr encore
plus les ordonnances à leur équipe
ce qui est quand même surréaliste c'est
qu'on est à trois jours du premier tour
des législatives
et là on parle d'un texte qu'on a jamais
vu bernard cazeneuve a déclaré hier à
propos des désordres de des ordonnances
et du des dunes code du travail
attention pas de faux procès il faut
être responsable et honnête au ps vous
êtes donc tous pas franchement en ligne
sur non on est responsable et honnête
sauf qu on demande simplement pour
l'instant à voir le texte est
globalement faut imaginer que le journal
le parisien lundi sur une version du
texte qui n'est pas la bonne libération
ce matin 1 re sur une version c'est
toujours pas là bas c'est quoi la
présidente depuis un mois on sait qu'à
la fin de l'été genre de noms seront
prises que les textes seront appliquées
au début de l'année 2018 et que le seul
jugement que pour apporter si si au bout
de ce débat que nous voulons
véritablement raccourcis parce que je
vous le dis les chômeurs n'attendent pas
les jeunes n'attendent pas ils ont
besoin de travailler aujourd'hui
n'attendent pas et vous voudriez que ça
dure pour qu'ils attendent pour qu'on
continue de voir monter le chômage de
masse vous le souvent c'est réellement
parce qu'en bougeant retirer foulée il
faut que je laisse passer rompu n'est
pas interrompue vraiment donc le texte
lui sera le monde soit celui qui va
sortir du conseil des ministres et puis
l'assemblée et le sénat pour siéger tout
le mois de juillet peut-être même
jusqu'au 4 ou 5 août
et puis avons fait j'ai tout le mois de
septembre rassurez vous on aura le temps
de débattre et les les élus en marla
public en marche sont pas là pour tout
accepté il aime les dons
nous discuterons coupable j'aurai le
françois patriat pour qu'on avance dans
cette émission rappelant que vous êtes
avec nous dans ce grand débat de premier
tour des élections législatives en
bourgogne et en franche comté avec nos
cinq invités autre thème de cet antre
élections finalement présidentielle
législatives la moralisation de la vie
publique on va rappeler constitue dans
la foulée aussi de la sphère de la
sphère fillon catherine alors ccai sur
ce texte
alors les ministres non bien sûr mais je
nous mettait en perspective voilà voilà
le ministre de la justice françois
bayrou a présenté son projet de
moralisation de la vie publique jeudi
dernier il ya donc une semaine alors les
points clés que j'ai retenu c'est
interdiction de recruter un membre de sa
famille pour un parlementaire et un pour
les membres du gouvernement aussi etc
etc
suppression de la réserve parlementaire
sujet a tellement tellement tellement de
fantasmes un système de remboursement en
frais réels et non plus donc des
indemnités de frais de mandat verser
tous les mois une peine d'inégibilité de
dix ans maximum pour toute personne qui
aura commis fraude fiscale favoritisme
ou corruption ou détournement de fonds
publics
et puis et puis surtout interdiction du
cumul dans le temps
c'est à dire que les députés les
sénateurs et les élus des exécutifs
locaux ne pourront plus exercer plus de
trois mandats consécutifs dans le temps
dans ma fonction dans la même fonction
oui oui alors alexandre emorine vous
êtes pour tous a forcément vous êtes
content alors il ya des choses qui vont
dans le bon sens mais il y avait
également des choses qui ne vont pas
assez loin vous parler par exemple de la
limitation à trois mandats dans le temps
pourquoi pas deux nous on suit les
recommander les recommandations de
l'association anticor qui propose de
mettre deux mandats successifs maximum
ça se passe pour le président de la
république par exemple depuis 2008 il
peut il est limité à deux mandats
on voit qu'il est en capacité de mettre
notre une politique en place il ya
également d'autres choses c'est qu'il ya
une énorme d'énormes manques notamment
sur la question des lodges comme dirait
monsieur mélenchon mais je dirais qu'il
ya un problème
gêné deux mandats successifs vous avez
les pratiques qu'il avait quand il était
aux mains des socialistes ce ne sont pas
ce ne sont pas les pratiques que nous
aurons dans la 6ème république
donc il ya énormément de manque aussi
sur la question des lobbys rien n'est
fait pour pour limiter les lobbys et les
liens qui pourrait y avoir entre
certains lobbys et les hommes politiques
mais dans le fond je pense pas que ce
soit une loi qui permette de redonner
confiance parce que cette loi ne
s'appelle pas loi de moralisation
c'est une loi pour redonner confiance
dans les institutions démocratiques
quelque chose comme ça je pense pas que
ce soit une loi qui redonne confiance ya
deux choisis avant tout une espèce
d'éthique personnelle ou si des élus et
il ya aussi le côté quand vous avez vous
même écrit les règles du jeu vous avez
confiance dans ce jeu là c'est pour ça
que nous on appelait aussi à une
constituante et ancienne république
parce que ça peut participer d'une
saviez pas mais non ça viendra pas
ouvrir mais on aime le combat aurait pu
rêver on peut encore la mettre à
l'assemblée nationale vous savez très
bien qu'à la loi constitutionnelle qui
le permet la constitution de la vème
vous voyez le port des avantages est
passée la sixième donc on peut très bien
merci donc le trailer magie n'est que
les le passager la 6ème république
tu as également un énorme signal de
retrouver confiance dans les
institutions ça n'en prend pas le chemin
reliant noirot le on va dire la
corruption éventuelle des élus c'est un
argument fréquent du front national
c'est une réponse c'est ce qui ne sera
pas forcément à toutes les affaires
c'est un c'est un constat je reviendrai
pas sur les affaires
on en a assez des battues pendant là
pendant la campagne présidentielle sur
ce projet de loi de mme organisation est
d'arriver en boutique
la justice tranchera et encore une fois
non lieu en sortira vainqueur
c'est bien d'agir pour la moralisation
de la vie politique
monsieur patriat on est tous d'accord
mais ce serait bien mais ce serait bien
que monsieur macron exige d'el hadj à la
démission de monsieur ferrand monsieur
ferrand qui durant la campagne
présidentielle s'est fait le chantre de
la moralisation et puis maintenant les
affaires lui tombe dessus où je pense
encore à madame de sarnez donc un pays
moraliser c'est c'est quand le peuple
est déjà respectée et le peuple sera
respectée comme déjà on instaurera une
véritable proportionnelle on aura
recours au référendum et non pas à la
gouvernance par ordonnance son bord 1 49
3 quand on respectera également
pluralisme politique
sur ce projet en lui-même il ya des
choses qui sont bien je pense à un sujet
que vous avez vous avez omis c'était là
la banque la banque d'oeuvres de
financement sans dire c'est un très bon
point parce que le front national quand
même est le seul parti politique qui
s'est vu refuser des emprunts bancaires
pour l'élection présidentielle et dont
les candidats aux élections législatives
ont encore eu des refus
un établi par les établissements
bancaires sans que ça c'est une c'est
une bonne chose mais manque par contre
des choses je pense notamment à la lutte
contre contre les conflits d'intérêts
est encore bas le fait d'interdire la
technique du pantouflage qui consiste à
ce que certains conseillers qui sont
dans le public passe dans le privé
reviennent donc je pense qu'il faut
aller plus loin et bien évidemment les
députés patriotes à l'assemblée
nationale veilleront attentivement un à
travailler à uvrer en ce sens un mot
françois patriat sur richard ferrand
bien sûr puis vous avez extraordinaire
moi je me suis il ya plein de gens qu'on
peut demander l'arrêt de françois fillon
abonde jean pas compris gilles richard
ferrand contient autant d'évocations
savez reconnaissez moi une chose je lui
fis plusieurs fois sur le gâteau jamais
une seule fois j'ai commenté la sphère
fille parce que moi je ne mets riches
pas ni en juge ni en censeur ni en
donneurs de morale sise à fait regarde
les élus leur conscience et la justice
et en aucun cas moi je ne me sens pas
dire keats d'exemple vous dire que moi
j'ai jamais embauché gt on me dit
dreamed a dream j'ai paraît que j'ai 101
ans demandeur accumulé rendez compte 98
diamant donc il est temps que la loi
macron cela pour faire disparaître les
élus des dom et je me dis je m'y
applique
mais moi je n'ai jamais embauché
personne j'ai pas attendu d'avoir 65 ans
et pour sa part fait répandre le chef
conjoint grogne des dépenses de chair
rejoint ce que vous faites tous mais moi
je suis pas là en terme de morale donc
je pense que pour monsieur demandé la
démission aujourd'hui de monsieur
ferrand chez les choses sont claires si
monsieur ferrand demain la justice dit
qu'il a fait un manquement délictueux à
la justice il quittera est immédiatement
gouvernement tant qu on est sur des
allégations aujourd'hui de la presse sip
anormal pour demander à quelqu'un de
démissionner sur des allégations
voilà quand elles ne sont pas
délictueuses et qu'elles ne sont pas
illégales voilà donc où est érigé en
censeur
regardez autour de vous
faite de mots attaché parlementaire qui
travaille au parlement et non pas pour
votre parti est comme ça vous pour aider
les débutants vous irez voir madame de
sarnez également une âme de cernay elle
est aujourd'hui simplement mise en cause
parce que votre leader des régionales
est allé comme une grande balance essayé
de dénoncer les autres pour s'excuser
sur ce que vous faites on a simplement
voulu rétablir un deux poids deux
mesures pourquoi le front national
seraient traités ainsi que tous les
persos qu'apparemment sauf le faraman
madame de sarnez nie tous les faits tu
portes plainte contre vous moi je ne
juge pas je ne lis pas je dis simplement
choses telles que je les ai nicolas
baudens est ce que richard ferrand
devait démissionner je pense que
juridiquement richard ferrand n'a pas
l'air coupable de ce que je lis
moralement
effectivement il devrait vraiment se
poser la question et je pense que ça
pose un vrai problème en tant que membre
du gouvernement est indélébile les
missions qu'ils occupent mais elle mixe
un débat personnel qu'il doit avoir avec
eux avec lui-même donc c'est pas moi
globalité avec un pacte la loi la
moralisation d'une certaine manière
c'est ce que conjonction des deux choses
oui ça fait extrêmement de mauvais genre
de par la concomitance eu d'effet justin
fait quand même par rapport au
renouvellement de la vie démocratique
c'est quand même la loi hollande du
quinquennat précédent sur le non cumul
des mandats
hier la nouvelle semblait effectivement
il ya un nouveau parti avec des
centaines à priori de député mais
surtout c'est le non cumul des mandats
qui se met enfin en place et qui a été
voté sous le quinquennat doit être
conduit le non-cumul faut expliquer ans
et un mandat de député à compatible la
lecture les sénateurs avec présidence du
conseil départemental et c'est m
justement comme parfois la loi bayrou je
pense que le nom qu on aurait pu réduire
également le nombre de parlementaires
sénateurs et députés c'était l'un des
projets des venues de macron voilà je ne
pense pas au sénat m pour répondre
prenons un petit peu mon collègue et ami
c'est que quand même la vraie nouveauté
dans les candidats aujourd'hui c'est
quand même bien marquer le fait il n'y a
que 25 députés sortants qui sont
aujourd'hui investis par aux marches 50%
des nouveaux candidats viennent de la
société civile ça veut dire deux jambes
qu'il ne vivait au no kaka de leur
mandat c'est le seul parti
c'est le seul parti à le faire et les
doublons 85 % de cas
sa mort ne sont pas la parole à la seule
balle autour de cette table sur 4 il ya
une simple il n'ya que 180 candidats sur
les cinq sens et qu'elle que vous avez
sur les 525 que vous avez investi qui
n'avait aucun mandat
non mais non j'entends par ce site
utilise le magnum dans quelqu'un qui ne
vit pas de l'argent public et
aujourd'hui quand on est maire d'une
petite commune et qu on a 200 euros par
mois
je considère que l'on ne vit pas de
l'argent public entonner conseiller
général non plus mais dans le donc ce
qu'ils disent ce saut qui ont des gros
mandats des exécutifs et des mandats
parlementaires dont la franche comté
vous avez quand même très largement
recycler des socialistes on pourrait
égrener leurs noms si vous voulez de
nice au mr barbier madame brulebois dans
notre circonscription qui est chef de
file au conseil départemental des
socialistes deux noms mais sa femme
n'est pas la france vont remonter en l2
si vous voulez on a beaucoup de social
parce qu'il soutient
- monsieur ferron me semble-t-il est
convoquée sur le jeu au chez le juge
pour atteinte aux biens et manquement au
devoir de probité et aux règles du code
de la mutualité même monsieur cahuzac
avait été appelé à démissionner par
monsieur hollande
il est incompréhensible que vous gardiez
monsieur ferrand ça c'est le premier
point alors sur la moralisation de la
vie à me garder longtemps que je fais
sur la morale tradition sur la
moralisation mais vous venez vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que vous portiez pas
de jugement mais voilà sur la
moralisation oui mais les français
attendent ça les français ont besoin de
reprendre confiance dans leurs hommes
politiques bien donc il faut moraliser
la vie politique alors sur les épouses
moi je pose la question qu'est ce qu'on
fait des maîtresses qu'est-ce qu'on fait
des concubines et qui s'occupait pas des
maîtresses danse la présentation de la
loi est ce que madame royal aurait pu
être ministre mme de monsieur hollande
avec cette loi il faut faire très
attention il ne faut pas si vous voulez
réagir comme ça rapidement à des défis
que je dise pour les téléspectateurs
peut-être de bourgogne qui vous
connaissent moins que les francs comtois
que vous êtes l'épousé de jacques
pélissard député maire de laon ce saut
directement exactement alors moi je
sentais particulièrement concerné
travaillait notamment les épouses est et
je travaille bénévolement à ses côtés je
sais ce que c'est que de travailler dès
n'est pas lui mentant ou pas je suis
aussi voulu qu'il faut pas faire dans
l'urgence pour face à fait comme depuis
le début de la vème république convia
pas toucher au statut donc je peux pas
dire que je ne précipite et aujourd'hui
quand vous regardez un contrat
d'assistant parlementaire
on doit dire le nombre d'heures qu'il
fait ou dans quel permanence jédir il ya
des moyens de contrôle donc mais il est
évident qu'un assistant parlementaire
doit travailler sa personne ne vous dira
le contraire
maintenant à dire que il faut aller sur
une note plus fort c'est françois fillon
interdiction fillon bis blanc dit le
contraire mais moi c'est toujours moi je
le dis je vous dis ce que je pense je
vous dise que ce sens elle très très
clairement
bon on va pas refaire la sphère fillon
non non vous aurez bien on ferait bien
de faire classer l affaire ferrand
aujourd'hui alors passer à la suite
on passe à la suite je le rappelle dans
ce débat ce grand débat bourgogne
franche comté de du premier tour des
élections législatives
il ya une dimension internationale vous
l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure au début de
l'émission vous dit de m'accrocher la
campagne on ne voit pas beaucoup avec
les candidats en revanche emmanuel
macron il a fabriqué du symbole dans cet
antre présidentielle législatives on l'a
vu avec vladimir poutine on l'a vu au
soir du retrait de donald trump des
accords de paris on va dire prendre la
tête de du monde écologiste est ce que
les français veulent ça alexandre et
marina président un peu gaulliste qui a
de la stature internationale et est ce
que de votre point de vue emmanuel
macron il fait ça parce que c'est ça qui
va aussi lui faire gagner les
législatives
je pense qu'il incarne aujourd'hui la
fonction du monarque présidentiel donc
ça
il rentre totalement dans ses habits là
sur la défense des accords de paris il
me semble quand même que c'est le
minimum syndical si je me permets de la
part du président de la république
française cette manière là bas avec un
message en anglais toutes façons si vous
voulez que les anglais vous comprennent
il faut aussi leur parler en anglais je
pense que c'est aussi une base
par contre il ya énormément d'effets de
communication mais il ya aussi
énormément de manque
au delà de la communication emmanuel
macron chantre du mouvement écologiste a
fait rire vraiment face et c'est
terrible on parle jamais du nucléaire
pour primer le maquereau les
perturbateurs endocriniens il n'en parle
jamais la question des pesticides ils
n'en parlent jamais bref il a qu'une
communication qui peut paraître
écologique grâce à donald trump parce
que dans notre plan énormément services
mais dans le fond il n'y a rien du tout
et sur la posture internationale
ce qu'il a fait avec la dîmière poutine
je salue jean luc mélenchon avait
toujours dit qu'il fallait parler avec
la russie pour régler les conflits que
nous nous at on pas dit on nous a
accusés d'être des poutinien d'être des
suppôts des dictateurs etc
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron fait ça lui
déroule même le tapis rouge et là tout
le monde me félicite très bien là dessus
en tout cas c'est très bien il faut
reprendre le dialogue avec la russie
nicolas boda ses premiers pas
internationaux d'emmanuel macro est ce
qu'il vous plaît c'est ce qu'il vous
bluff ou pas du tout d'où ils sont très
très réussie
je pense que c'est une réussite que ce
soit avec trunks way to think so niveau
du sommet européen on ne l a bien posé
le problème parce que contrairement à ce
que vous disiez par rapport à mélenchon
il souhaitait aussi revenir
potentiellement surprendre des
frontières de la russie il écrivait ce
qui comme un autre débat donc je pense
qu'il ait carne bien et puis ça raconte
dans un système médiatique donc ça
qu'actuellement c'est le plus jeune
président de la république au monde donc
ça et c'est toute une nouvelle
génération notamment être le premier
ministre canadien
donc je pense que les français sont
aussi contents de ce rajeunissement
puisque pas eu depuis des décennies
d'aidés signé un président aussi jeune
pianiste belgique il ya le noir au que
pensez-vous de cvc premier passage à
nationaux ses premiers pas d'abord on se
rend compte que que le système
médiatique n'a eu de cesse un poste
présidentiel et puis encore aujourd'hui
on sent ces manuels manqueront en fer en
faire le chouchou des le chouchou des
médias donc normes oms
ramé je vais ramener contre ça dans
cette campagne des législatives vous sur
le terrain pour prendre tout moi sur la
campagne des législatives sur le terrain
des dogues dans ma seule inscription
tout se passe bien aussi je ne vois pas
le candidat parachuté en marche assure
sur la sur la question du climat et puis
dans d'autres circonscriptions également
sur la sur la question du climat bien
évidemment que nous regrettons la
décision de donald trump mais je pense
qu'il faut également saluer la décision
qu'il a prise il a tenu une de ses
promesses de compétences élevées et vont
on regrette je regrette a parfaitement
le retrait de l'accord de paris mais par
contre je salue le tir le fait que
donald trump est tenue est tenu une
promesse de sa campagne je sais monsieur
patriat que le fait d'avoir des nations
souveraines ça vous dérange ça vous
dérange pas cher c'est à dire qu'elles
s'ouvrent à sur la sur la question sur
la question des climats ça pose un autre
problème c'est le fait de rompre avec la
mondialisation sauvage pour protéger le
climat il faut déjà revenir à un système
de production qui est local il faut
repenser à une écologie orienté vers la
relaxe la relocalisation
il faut cesser d'importer des produits
qui nous viennent qui nous viennent
d'ailleurs que nous pourrions produire
localement et qui ne respectent
notamment aucune clause environnementale
et sociale et il faut il faut également
voir plus loin
on oublie dans cet accord halle et sur
la sur la question de l'écologie en
elle-même le développement de la filière
hydrogène qui est trop souvent oubliée
ou encore les circuits courts et ça ce
sont des propositions que nous ne
défendrons la filière hydrogène des
circuits courts et lauriane pélissard
est ce que vous êtes comme la presse
comme dealer noir au bleu fait parler la
stature internationale d' emmanuel
macron non mais moi je voulais dit tout
à l'heure je pense que effectivement il
a été très bon face à donald trump
bon ceci étant il faut pas non plus
mettre sur un piédestal l'accord de
paris parce que rappelez vous tout le
monde a dit que l'accord de paris
n'était pas si extraordinaire que ça à
chaque pays jusqu'en 2022 ou 2025 fait
exactement ce qu'il veut et il n'y aura
de contraintes qu après donc la corde
paris était un petit accord ce n'était
quand même ça la grande
la grande firme yeux ça c'est un est
très grand et on aurait pu faire
beaucoup plus on aurait pu faire mouche
il est absolument rencontrer ne vous
n'êtes pas d'accord vous pensé que
c'était un très bon ailleurs très grand
art le feu n'ayant pas contraignant
m'attendais le fait que les etats-unis
se retrouvent désormais avec la syrie et
puis je crois le nicaragua comme seul
pays non signataires a effectivement
donald trump respecte ses engagements
électoraux mais c'est quand même une
aberration dire ça vis-à-vis des 7
milliards d'habitants sur cette planète
quand même d'ailleurs c'est un risque
majeur est donc ça veut dire quand même
que moi j'incite les français à aller
voter parce qu'un résumé en votant pour
n'importe qui on se retrouve avec ce
genre de décisions cirque une personne à
la tête de ce tapis de 250 millions
d'habitants peut se permettre de dire eh
bien moi à titre personnel donald trump
je romps la coop 21 je trouve ça
extrêmement grave donc la nageur rien
pour moi même si je reproche à l'accord
l'accord interne ne pas avoir a été
assez forte
la parité assez loin et demain et de ne
pas avoir été assez loin
bon voilà maintenant comme je voulais
dire si on veut que notre pays soit
respectée il faudra qu'il prenne des
mesures en interne qui lui permette de
redresser ses finances
et là on sera écoutée et bien vous me
donnez l'enchaînement pour françois
patriat le président préside là avec
cette image président et c'est pas
gouverner françois patriat pour
l'instant ferme pas vraiment d'abord je
voudrais quand même dénoncé une fête
c'est que au nom de la souveraineté
on peut mettre à mal la vie de la terre
et la survie de la terre au nom de la
souveraineté d'un pays
j'entends ça samedi ce qu'elle avait dit
répété à souveraineté au nom de la
souveraineté on peut mettre sans toucher
la dilation d'un président qui a été élu
d autres régions
aujourd'hui l'attitude du chef de l'état
depuis son élection je crois que les
français à la fois le découvre
l'approuvent et commence même à l'aîné
je fais pas ici de la micromania
ce que je regarde c'est que les gestes
touche emmanuel macron et peser calculer
et réfléchi quand ils remontent les
champs elysées furent une voiture
militaire
il donne à la défense sa primauté
lorsqu'il va voir les soldats blessés à
clamart c'est au terrorisme qu'il
s'adresse quand il rencontre madame
merkel c'est à l'europe qu'il s'adresse
aussi et chacun savait l'ensemble de vos
confrères ont salué moi je les vois où
paris ailleurs chaque jour
les quinze premiers jours considère
aujourd'hui comme un sofa de la façon
dont il respecte aujourd'hui admiré ac
axe par madame merkel en tant que chef
d'état chancelière par aujourd'hui le
discours de fermeté qu'il a eu il a dit
à la fois des américains et des russes
la façon dont au g7 il s'est imposé
naturellement tous ceux qui doutaient
avant de lui en disant mais dans des
icaunais l'économie il est trop jeune il
n'a pas d'expérience il n'a pas été lui
connais pas le régalien aujourd'hui sont
contraints de remarquer que dans ce
domaine le domaine régalien ou le
contester beaucoup avant et bien qu'il
fera de même avec son programme de alors
on avance dans cette émission avec un
dernier chapitre
c'est un peu de projection dimanche
premier tour des législatives
on va vous remontrer à nouveau alors on
arrête de parler de camembert ce sondage
en rentrant un peu plus dans le détail
du sondage 385 415 pour le public en
marche on est d'accord c'est des
projections 100 125 pour la droite
25 à 35 pour le ps 12 à 22 pour la
france insoumise 5 à 15 pour le front
national d'autres sondages donnent des
fourchettes un peu différente on va dire
mais on est globalement dans les mêmes
équilibres l'expression qui revient
c'est pleins pouvoirs alexandre emorine
même s'il ya des variations à trois
jours d'une élection c'est rare que les
sondages se trompent autant il va avoir
les pleins pouvoirs à la neil mac rond
c'est le risque en tout cas mes fins je
le répéte 1 là où on a une intention de
vote sur un premier mois des vacances
mais le risque en tout cas oui c'est
clair c'est d'avoir un monarque
républicain qui est qui dispose des
pleins pouvoirs pour faire son programme
on en a parlé tout à l'heure notamment
sur la réforme du marché du travail
donc c'est pour ça que nous on part du
principe qu'il faut envoyer un maximum
de députés insoumis pourquoi parce que
nous allons porter les questions
sociales écologiques et institutions de
nécessaire nous dit un seul dans cette
campagne
vous n'etes aligné avec le pc qui parce
que entre vous et le pcc j'avais 7
millions de gens qui ont voté pour le
programme de jean luc mélenchon il n'y a
aucune raison qu'ils ne revoient pas une
seconde fois pour pour ce programme et
la ceni la raison ça peut être par
exemple les candidats du parti
communiste déjà coûté qui ont fait
campagne avec vous pour jean luc
mélenchon et les communistes n'ont pas
le même programme que nous c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qui ne sont pas liés avec
nous ils ont fait ce choix là très bien
nous en tout cas on est en cohérence et
on porte en porte exactement le
programme qui s'appelle l'avenir en
commun donc on part du principe que les
gens qui ont aimé une fois le programme
ils vont l'aimer une seconde fois
également
et et tout est ouvert si les 7 millions
de personnes votent pour les candidats
soumis aux législatives nous pouvait-on
deuxième tour en 80 % des circonstances
je parlais tout à l'heure de l'après
débat manqué de matériel
est ce que le non choix de jean-luc
mélenchon entrecôte il a dit je ne
voterai pas macron je ne vote pas machin
etc
ça a été très confuse a été très vous
oui hélas il a dit qu'il prenait pas
position et c est ce que ça vous pensez
pas quand même que ça déçu une partie
justement de votre set de vos 7 millions
d'électeurs
honnêtement je ne pense pas je ne pense
pas parce que moi j'ai énormément de
gens qui disent aussi merci enfin y'a
pas un état major parisien qui nous a
dit il faut voter ça sinon vous êtes si
vous êtes des grands méchants et je
répète en même temps que jean luc
mélenchon a déclaré dès le début dès le
vendredi en tout cas pas une voix marine
le pen donc pour tous ceux qui poussent
aussi des cris d'orfraie en dix ans il a
tardé pour dire pas une voix marine le
pen etc
je rappelle que lionel jospin en 2002
n'a parlé aussi que le vendredi et ça
personne ne comprenait que nous aussi on
allait aussi une petite déception je
vous le cache pas comme je disais tout à
l'heure on est passé pas très loin mais
bon voilà donc la position moi je suis
aussi fier d'être dans un mouvement où
on respecte les positions des gens on
part du principe que bien entendu pas
une voix au front national parce que
c'est totalement incompatible avec nos
valeurs nous sommes umanis nous sommes
républicains mais à partir de ce moment
là il ya plusieurs options qui sont
ouvertes il ya aucun anathèmes qui est
jeté ça sert à une chamane repos mais on
a redonné mois juste pour terminer ça va
peut-être se reposer aux élections
législatives cette cette question là
mais c'est pour ça que nous on veut pas
travailler sur des candidats du front
national l'onu et flore et vous
glisserez dans certains cas inversement
mais de toute façon
de toute façon on part du principe que
les français sont adultes français sont
majeurs on n'a pas besoin de leur donner
des ordres ou des consignes ils savent
ce qu'ils avaient à faire
je pense que tous ici ou même tous ceux
qui nous regardent à 20h et une seconde
savait ce qu'il voulait faire pour
second tour ils n'ont pas eu besoin de
consignes de la part de jean luc
mélenchon de cambadélis de figure est
quand même dans les enquêtes d'opinion
je pense qu'elle a un peu plus de ma pas
plus d'une centaine de députés pour la
droite disent les disent les sondages
alors saf se sera pas énorme par rapport
à eux est ce que il y aura peut-être
deux groupes aussi à l'intérieur
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un risque pour
vous avec un point d'appui semaine
c'était ce matin je crois à la jupe et
qui va soutenir une candidate dans
marche
non mais jean pierre raffarin qui ce
matin chantait les louanges des manuels
macron sur une chaîne d'information
continue oui non mais on a été sonnée si
vous voulez il ya six mois on devait
gagner cette élection législative sans
difficulté on va pas revenir sur ce qui
s'est passé on aura cinq ans pour le
faire je crois moi j'en profite voilà
non on a été ce n'est donc aujourd'hui
si vous voulez bail c'est possible qu'on
parte parfois un petit peu en bande en
bande désorganisée
mais il est important il serait un bon
résultat pour vous le plus de candidats
élus possible c'est vraiment là
sentiment qu'à une pilote dans l'avion
ce que je voudrais dire ce que je veux
ce que je voudrais dire aux électeurs
aujourd'hui c'est que 1
une assemblée monochrome c'est très
mauvais il faut que le débat politique
se fasse à l'assemblée nationale est pas
dans la rue et si nous avons que deux
députés macro nist le débat se fera dans
la rue donc moi j'appelle véritablement
les électeurs de la droite et du centre
à revenir vers la famille politique
nous avons été privés d'une élection
présidentielle alors peut-être un peu de
notre faute peut-être de la faute des
autres
ça c'est une question que quiconque va
pas tranché aujourd'hui mais nous avons
été privés d'une élection présidentielle
donc aujourd'hui il faut que les
électeurs et les électrices fasse
confiance à nos candidats nos candidats
ils seront constructifs
lorsque emmanuel tiff sait ce que ça
veut dire que dans ce groupe l'est
républicain je repose la question de
lilian autrement est-ce qu'il y en a qui
soutiendront macron et d'autres qui
seront opposants à maquereau moi je vous
ai dit je pense que l'on va vers eux des
majorités de projet et pas des majorités
de partie on soutiendra une bonne un bon
projet de loi on soutiendra de bonnes
idées on soutiendra
là tout le travail qui va être fait pour
libéraliser l'économie
on dira à monsieur macron non au niveau
du financement et de vos réformes
financières de votre loi de finances il
faut faire différemment il faut imposer
plus de 10 il faut imposer plus
d'efforts je pense que ça sera très très
nécessaire donc il faut que les
républicains puissent jugnot être
présent être présente dans cette
assemblée et parler avec le président de
la république il est l'avenir salaire
qu'on reçoit patriat qui voudraient pas
de mon ressort
alors voir qu'on doit conclure en 2
minutes chacun
les incidences des missions qu ici si
vous avez j'avais quatre cas de figure
vous avez le front national et la rosa
soumises qui sont dans l'opposition
ils sont donc contre la politique du
gouvernement il le dit ils vont faire
c'est pas avec ça
ce qu'emmanuel macro va avancer madame
pélissard et les jours la cohabitation
elle veut qu'on donne une majorité à la
droite classique à cohabitation c'est à
dire la stérilisation et on pourra pas
avancer les socialistes et dont ils sont
pour le soutien à la carte à dire tout
ce qu'ils valent et bien on va aller
voter mais les ordonnances on votera pas
moi je suis pour une majorité pour le
président pas monarque républicain
ce que je veux c'est que le président
réussisse qui réussissent les réformes
sociales les réformes économiques dans
la justice et dans l'équité et dans la
liberté
je jugerai le chef de l'état à la fin de
son mandat sur deux critères 1
si le chômage a régressé 2 si le front
national a régressé sur ces deux
critères la cessoie qui sera votre sujet
par les français et pour ça on n'a pas
besoin d'opposants il a besoin d'une
majorité et alors là c'est le disait
qu'il allait déjà jugé sur la diminution
du chômage la vie vous avez échoué et
conscience
moi j'ai vu faire mal aux accusations je
parle pas de cohabitation la
cohabitation c'est de l'affrontement
moi je vous dis qu'on peut avoir ce que
dit monsieur baroin il veut premier
ministre de monsieur marron mais
monsieur monsieur côté y arriver
monsieur baroin peut vouloir être le
premier ministre qu'importe c'est le
président qui choisira son premier
ministre et qui choisira à l'issue des
élections
quelle sera la formation qui a choisi
pour cinq ans - maïs il a choisi pour
cinq ans très bien après les
législatives
d'accord dans l'opposition ferme
nous serons une opposition ferme face
aux projets néfastes porté par emmanuel
macron je pense notament tous les
princes et les facettes à 7 à cette
réforme de du code du travail
ah mais nous serons également une force
de proposition parce que quand j'entends
autour de cette table que ce soit madame
pélissard qui se revendique clairement
macro compatibles mais les électeurs
français les électeurs les électeurs
français ne doivent pas se tromper si
glisse un bulletin les républicains y
glisse un bulletin manuel macron donc
moi j'invite tous les électeurs à
glisser un bulletin patriotes en votant
pour marine le pen et les candidats du
front national qui permettront d'être la
seule et unique opposition face à manu
macrovision parce qu'un groupe c 15 à
l'assemblée dans un certain nombre de
sondages la fourchette vous peut vous
placer en dessous des 15 exemple marine
le pen et leur bonne position à hénin
beaumont
gilbert collard il est en position très
difficile sedan se pose la question du
de la delà de la vie politique actuelle
et du pluralisme et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut mettre en place de la
proportionnelle à toutes les élections
pour que toutes les sensibilités
les sensibilités politiques puissent
être représentés quand on présente 11
millions d'électeurs c'est intolérable
contre ce qu'on est que actuellement que
deux députés donc bien évidemment
j'appelle tous les français à voter
massivement pour les candidats patriotes
qui seront les seuls à défendre la
souveraineté nationale face face à
l'ultra libéralisme et à la candidate et
et aux projets menés par macron agir
aussi face au terrorisme
parce que on n'a pas parlé durant la
même tribu de reprogrammer bien falloir
combien d'attentats
combien d'attentats avant de considérer
le fondamentalisme islamiste comme comme
un totalitarisme voteront pas sur les
temps de parole et encore pour nous
mêmes une opposition bienveillante au
cas par cas on votera les différents
textes notamment celui sur la loi de la
moralisation de la vie publique de
bayrou tout ça c'est effectivement une
très bonne mesure
d'autres mesures sont très intéressantes
le nombre de douze élèves par classe en
zone d'éducation prioritaire c'est une
très bonne mesure mais il faut expliquer
comment financièrement les mairies le
financent simplement en quelques mots il
est important qu'il y ait beaucoup de
députés socialistes entre le
mélenchonisme et le maquereau nice il ya
les socialistes et le socialisme un
véritable avenir et je pense qu'elle me
qu'on ne doit pas se satisfaire de
nouvelle majorité
non parce que parce que sur les ordis
sur les ordonnances
on souhaite globalement qu'il y ait un
débat au parlement ne l'aiment pas et
dans la majeure part président très peu
j'ai dit précédemment suivant les textes
sur les ordonnances que je sois là car
on souhaite on souhaite soutien à la 15
souhaite qu'il y ait un débat
parlementaire
il serait intéressant aussi de dire aux
bourguignons et au franc comtois combien
il ya deux classes de cp en zep en
bourgogne franche comté il y en a pas
beaucoup
les parents vont être un peu étonné de
voir que les classes sont toujours aussi
sûr serge françois
il nous reste nous reste plus beaucoup
fait en deux minutes d'émission avant
sur la participation de votre point de
vue elle va être faible la participation
dans ces élections
alexandre emorine vous le sentez comment
elles risquent d'être faibles en même
temps partout on annonce que le résultat
est déjà jouée d'avancé
forcément ça n'engage pas les gens à les
déplacer donc c'est pour ça que nous on
dit surtout ne donnez pas les plats
pouvoir emmanuel macron donc il faut se
mobiliser je répète sept millions
d'électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
peuvent en tout cas belle je aller voter
parce que voter on se retrouve parfois
exigible comme donald trump aux états
unis on voit les conséquences que ça
donc voter c'est extrêmement important
et c'est un devoir civique
donc il encore temps d'aller voter ce
dimanche pour les deux tours et sur la
participation à l'hélice a aussi vous le
sentez comment
j'appelle tous les électeurs à aller
voter à mettre un gros bleu dans
l'assemblée nationale de façon à ce que
nous puissions avoir un débat
démocratique fort intelligent qui fait
avancer la france
je ne pense pas du tout je souhaite que
le maximum de français apportent leur
soutien massivement qu'il le montre au
succès des manuels jeux faurisson l'afp
que vous perdiez un certain nombre
d'électeurs populaire sur cette
participation
moi j'invite tous les électeurs
patriotes partout en france à se
déplacer massivement dans les urnes des
cours pour aller mode et pas glissé un
bulletin roues pour les candidats front
national qui sont la seule l'unique
opposition entre ceux qui la crèche vous
coupent merci à tous les saints parce
que c'est la fin de ce débat
merci tous les cinq avaient répondu à
notre invitation plus que quelques jours
de campagne on vous rappelle que la
soirée électorale bien sûr pour ne rien
rater
en bourgogne et en franche comté ce sera
chez nous sur france 3 on se retrouve on
se retrouverait en quatrième merci à
tous les cinq
bonsoir avoir passé une soirée ensemble
au revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]